I have a creative process and I think
you need to myself I will find i started
in advertising so i would really sit
down with art directors usually and we
would think about different ways to
solve a problem advertising his problem
solving a creative way and we would
throw everything out I mean we were
never embarrassed to throw it an idea it
could come from anywhere I mean it could
come from another you know I never stole
from advertising but you'd look at art
you'd walk around and sometimes their
relationships between things if you're
doing something for example for for a
car you kind of think visually about
that and then you try to completely do
the opposite so how do you do something
you don't shoot on the road how do you
do solve this problem without show your
car my process is usually how to do
something really new but to solve the
problem and communicate it and I think
that's like is going in different
directions starting with sometimes
something completely obscured say in the
office wow there's a straw what can we
do with the straw and solve this problem
that the car gets better gas mileage and
it starts that way and then someone will
say something else and someone will say
something else and then you'll come up
with a visual idea that may say that
would be really interesting I've never
seen that a car commercial how can we
make that relate to this problem we're
trying to solve so a lot of it comes
from from that and connects back to
things we do but I don't know where it
comes from but the smartest people most
creative people I know you know they
haven't built in they just their nature
is to come up with things and it's their
other brains work that way and I think
that mine works that way comes at things
from different angles all the time I
don't know why it does but it comes very
naturally to me to do these things on it
doesn't come naturally for me to do a
lot of obvious things that most people
can do naturally but one thing that is
natural for me is to kind of creatively
solve problems or